is there another comedian who had the
the tenacity
the entrepreneurial Spirit to rent
Arenas themselves like has anybody ever
done that and what what was that even
like the first time I rented Arena was
mid uh mid to late 2000s and it was
really because after everything that
happened with my brother I was in a real
bind and I had everybody
um in my it's funny I had accounting and
people in my accounting who almost very
quickly were like don't need us anymore
I mean that's how setback I was it was
almost like we don't need to do any
accounting with you because you're kind
of at you know square one you told me
last night that you had just bought a
house and they were like hey they were
like you're gonna have to get out of
that house yeah it was it was two weeks
away from like paper or work being
signed and they were like no how old are
you oh like dyscalculus so sometimes
numbers I was 28 29.
um and then so they were like they were
like you know don't do this well I was
like I am going to keep this house it
was my dream house
and my idea was I had some money he
couldn't take that was in like some
stocks that just weren't easy to just
you know power of attorney out and I
took 450 000 which was pretty much
mostly all I had to my name
and I was like
how do you rent an arena and I started
calling Arenas basically just calling
and finding out it's just it's just a
haul right and when there's no game in
there it's just like except for a couple
of insurance things that you got to
cover back then maybe it's different now
I was like it's just a big Hall
especially B Arenas the big VFW it I I
found that out so I rented I don't
remember the first two I rented but I
remember the door is mine the merch is
mine we did some deal on the on the um
you know food and drinks
and at the end of the two nights I'd
already put like a million eight or
something back in my pocket and I went
all right here's 200 000 rent me two
more that are within that range and we
just kept renting the B ones or maybe
even a C1 here or there packing it out
and then I kept renting them I probably
rented honestly like 80 Arenas on my own
and just was like by the end of the year
when I saw him in court I'd already made
everything back he stole it what took me
like 17 years I pretty much banked in a
year unbelievable
it's all right but I think it was Barry
Katz told me about you renting Arenas
yeah and uh like is that is that a model
that anybody anybody else adopted no but
I know that other people you know they
just doing it now yeah but back then it
was like I knew it was uh of that level
and I'm like [ __ ] I I you know I want to
be there but I also don't wanna I can't
split with anybody I don't want to do
any like
you know I don't want to do any I need
as much as what I can retain to get my
company and everything and be like you
know back with my head above water and I
also just had a personal grievance
against my brother that like just
completely honest I was like when I see
him a year from now in court I want to
[ __ ] look at him and say I have it
all back
I just wanted to be able to say I have
it all back I grievancy mean resentment
yeah I had like uh yeah I I like a fire
burning inside him was there any
gratitude that if he never did that you
wouldn't start running 100. Dave told me
that last night yeah I mean he said had
that not happened I would not have
reinvented myself you know why I'm okay
with it
because a past the Betrayal and
everything that breaks inside of you
when somebody you love does that betrays
with Love Worth I mean betrayal is bad
enough betrayal with love
but I can actually look back and it's
like I got a lot of love from him I had
years of love with him there was great
memories there's things that I can still
look at and laugh I used to think he
rewrote my past there was an ERA I was
like I couldn't look at a picture
without being like that's not the
[ __ ] guy in the picture
and then just through doing the work
and having great mentors and people
around me to help me it was like no I
had great years with him everything
happened the way it was supposed to
happen in order for me to really feel
um like I was standing on my own without
being shrouded in the negativity that
obviously he had around me for a lot of
years that I didn't know until it was
gone and once it was gone it was like oh
wow this is what it feels like to have
like you know clear air around you so
yeah it's like and I still have a great
relationship with his son I'm super
close with my nephew I love him it's
like everything that needed to come from
that did
crazy so what uh is your brother still
in prison now no he served for like five
or six of eight years and then he was
released and he's never taught nonsense
poor guy yeah you learned a little bit
on that Comedy Tour man the time he was
you jumped right on the right side
sure is there uh in like the the justice
system for for that situation is there
like restitution or do they just say oh
yeah there's a [ __ ] ton of money we
don't expect he could ever pay yeah so
it's like there's all these promises and
restitution in like the 48 charges or
whatever that he was brought up on
um you know equals like
a dollar a month that you get back at
some point somewhere but I honestly
looked at that and I was like whatever
the punishment is give it to them but uh
I there's nothing from that that I need
anymore right would you ever see him
again and be like dude we're cool I will
tell you this because I have to be
careful what I talk about at this point
I'm working on a documentary with a
great group of people right now and it's
really about that era the highest of
highs of how did I do what's my
philosophy and how did I get there and
stand up and really what is the cool fun
funny [ __ ] that happened and then the
other side is talking about my brother
it's like The Empire Strikes Back of
of comedy series and if I do it right
and if I answer your question in some
regard uh when this is on a streamer
maybe or if it is it should be either
under comedy or true crime or maybe both
yeah that's kind of where I wanted to
live like dude that was [ __ ] funny
but that was [ __ ] up that's hopefully
where I wanted to be dad cheer crime is
my [ __ ] that's mine too yeah damn it are
you familiar with JCS on uh YouTube no
oh my God
yeah it's a criminal psychology I just
love I'll dial in on that I watch all of
that I'm still watching like old
Forensics Files
particular bangers okay cool okay all
right episode nine yeah do you feel like
uh do you feel like you had a lot like
when you had that hate inside of you you
had a lot of like energy blocking you
from like going forward in life and then
finally once you got over that like your
life started taking off again like do
you feel like there was some energy that
held you back and once you're able yeah
sure I was in the undertow moment for
you know a few years because ready
uh it wasn't hate it was like
humiliation it was humiliation was the
number one thing because oh this is
tough tonight we grew up in a household
that because of my dad's alcoholism
there was a lot of humiliation attached
to his behaviors and so that was the key
word like we got to look like we're cool
because you know my mom and I were like
oh we don't want to we don't want people
to be able to like take our power with
this even though we already knew the
neighborhood knew and I think there was
just a whole thing of like
I thought I'd presented myself in my
life and career as like oh this is a
what self-made looks like and then he
made me look or feel at that time stupid
like I'd made the worst decision and I
knew some people were using that like
weaponizing that and saying like oh
you're not as smart as you have claimed
to be by getting to where you did so
yeah it was more like it was like
humiliation coupled with
the inevitable come down of a career at
the same moment that that was all kind
of like happening
so it was like oh man this feels even
more like they're pushing me down the
hill even though I could look back later
and be like no I had my run and it was
awesome but but you're back and you feel
better like what happened to get you to
like oh man I just I love stand up I
love making people I'm at my core I just
love making people laugh I love I'm very
curious person and I love getting on
stage I'm a Storyteller I love improv I
I love human behavior I like
conversations that can be real and
gritty and I want to be able to take
stand up into more places than I had
taken it when I when I hit I had like
six tools pretty sharp but I was like
I'm still lacking in so many things that
I wish I was better at and it took me
more years to get like what does that
mean like I want to be more
introspective I knew some things that I
needed better in my storytelling I I
wanted to be more uh transparent about
like failure equal to like
um not just going up there and being
like look what I did how cool is that
like being able to go up and be like
here's the [ __ ] sandwich that I eight
and and I ate every bite and when you
could talk about all those things it's
just such a different
it permeates the world in a different
way because now your laughter is
Meaningful but your poignancy is
Meaningful and then and then from that
all I've all I've had the opportunity to
share in like thousands of versions of
this now where it's like I've grown up
with people that are like hey man I'm
glad we keep each other in check your
comedy keeps me in check your truth
keeps me in check just a nice place to
be and it's a nice place when you meet
somebody like him to where
um Gilchrist
where somebody knows I don't want
anything from you I don't need anything
from you I just want to share a little
something with you it's a really great
feeling especially in the industry when
you meet somebody you know that's what
Jerry Lewis was for me when I met Jerry
Lewis he became like a mentor in many
ways like a father figure he didn't want
or need anything from me and it was just
such a valuable correspondence and
currency of conversation with him and
that's what I want to be able to be in
my comedy and just
you know in real time yeah with anybody
with any of my relationships it's called
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on Amazon and type in Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude